a political threat looms over much of
the world developed countries as well as
many emerging countries such as in
China's case are beginning to see the
effects that demographic ageing and many
public services and sustainability can
cause with increasing concern along with
pensions health is another of the fields
that generate the most uncertainties and
fears an increasingly aging population
and the emergence of new and expensive
medical technologies have raised some
very important questions will we be able
to pay for a quality health care system
or will we be condemned to a precarious
health situation that affects our life
prospects is there a successful model
that can lead the way other alternatives
well in this video we're going to look
at a system that we may more or less
like but which we should definitely know
about and take into account throughout
this debate it's nice have a look at it
[Applause]
[Music]
check out the following graph it shows
the country leaving the third world
behind in becoming one of the richest
areas on the planet 35 years ago
Singapore in Spain at the same per
capita income today however the format
more than doubles the Spanish per capita
income in 2015 Singapore's per capita
income was 86 thousand 100 dollars per
year and Spain's
was just thirty four thousand seven
hundred and fifty dollars but even if we
look at countries like Finland Denmark
Sweden Germany or the United States as
examples we'd be able to see that
Singapore is much richer than any of
them however it's often said that
Singapore's example isn't good enough
because their wealth essentially comes
from a financial sector that is much
larger than any of the aforementioned
countries and that's true but it's not
the only key to this small States
success the weight of Singapore's
financial sector isn't big enough to
explain these differences in per capita
income in fact if we were to eliminate
the effects of these countries different
financial sector sizes Singapore would
still be much richer than the others
because actually both trade and
manufacturing are more important in
Singapore than the financial sector
we're talking about one of the largest
merchandise exporting countries in the
entire world
for example the proportion of electronic
material that this country exports in
relation to its GDP is larger than the
proportion of anything exported by
countries like Spain Sweden Denmark or
even Germany so the question now becomes
how did Singapore achieve such a high
level of prosperity well if we wanted to
simplify it we could say that Singapore
is the second freest economy in the
world according to the index of economic
freedom published annually by the
Heritage Foundation in the wall street
journal it's public spending for example
is half of the us's and 1/3 of Sweden's
listen do the words of the historic
president of Singapore Lee Kuan Yew
which successfully reflects the real
foundations of this country's economic
success
when most of the third world was deeply
suspicious of exploitation by Western
multinational corporations Singapore
invited them in they helped us grow
brought in technology and know-how and
raised productivity levels faster than
any alternative strategy could have Lee
Kuan Yew
Singapore's success is therefore not due
to the financial industry but due to the
same reasons that have led to the growth
of other economies legal security low
taxes monetary stability and moderate
regulations a commitment to the free
market has made this country becoming in
many areas an example to follow
[Music]
and we're not only talking strictly
about economics here but also certain
social issues such as health yeah you
heard that right Singapore is also a
role model in terms of health policy
an impossible challenge let's take a
look for example at Spain's case the
country whose health system is
considered one of the most efficient on
the planet well the problem is that
beyond being coral it isn't sustainable
see in just a decade the total cost of
the Spanish health system has almost
doubled and everything indicates that as
a result of the aging population and the
demand for new and expensive health
technologies this trend will be
unstoppable and will continue to worsen
year after year and don't think that
this only happens in Spain not at all in
fact medical bills that is the
sustainability of health systems is a
widespread problem in other developed
countries so the question that arises is
how can we overcome these challenges and
ensure the sustainability of healthcare
systems
a good model which is never taken into
account could perhaps be that of a
completely free health system a system
in which demand and supply are
determined by the market and not in
political offices this could lead to
some benefits for one more money for
families thanks to lower taxes and a
precautionary saving level against any
ailments that may arise that's higher
than the present one this would allow
for direct primary care payments and
insurance against minor ailments common
issues and more expensive treatments
[Music]
another benefit would be a greater
diversity of and competition among
different health centers this would mean
that given the threat of being displaced
in the markets productivity
differentiation and innovation would be
promoted in other words with achieve a
wide range of services that would
positively impact both the quality of
the service and lead to lower prices
[Music]
competition is usually the best formula
to guarantee better goods and services
for consumers and healthcare it's not
any different however nowadays no
country uses all of these principles and
no the US healthcare system as we'll see
isn't precisely a free-market model now
there is a country that has used some of
these characteristics since it has done
so with extraordinary results so let's
consider Singapore's case
[Music]
[Applause]
a model for health reform right now
Singapore has the best health care
system in the world it's top quality and
costs practically half of that of
Spain's health care system and less than
a third of that of the United States but
this isn't just a matter of lower cost
it's also and above all about quality
and results see life expectancy at birth
in Singapore is two to three years
longer than in Britain or the United
States its infant mortality rate is
among the lowest in the world and is
almost half that of the United States
Great Britain Australia Canada or France
and in general its mortality rates are
impressive compared to most Western
countries now the question we can ask
ourselves here is how did they achieve
such success well in this case they have
achieved it fundamentally by using
market criteria first of all the main
feature of the Singapore model doesn't
just lie in the fact that more than 60%
of all health spending is private Spurs
that to a large extent it is paid
directly by users that is co-payments is
the norm here
[Music]
but not everyone pays the same when they
go to a hospital there are public and
private centers as well as five levels
five classes a B 1 B 2 plus B 2 and C
each of these letters gives users a
different service for example Class A
gets you a private room and a choice of
doctor a while in Class C the room is
shared and the doctor is assigned by the
hospital of course each class has a
different cost if a user chooses Class A
they pay for everything instead if they
choose Class C the government subsidizes
80 percent of the cost but where do
people get some money to pay for health
care well from the same place as in
other countries from the wealth that
they generate from their work the
difference is that the huge
contributions that governments usually
collect they're saved in Singapore in a
mandatory way yes citizens have special
accounts where they keep this money they
can only use these accounts for certain
purposes such as paying their pensions
their children's education their home or
their health in the case of health care
the account is known as Medisave and is
used to pay for doctor's visits
hospitalizations medications etc this is
the second key point of Singapore's
medical system thanks to this formula
demand is self-regulating and people can
manage how to spend the money they
accumulate in these accounts for example
by accessing different kinds of care
whether they want to receive or be
hospitalized in hospitals with fewer
comforts but which are cheaper or with
more services and higher costs
decreasing redundant and superfluous
consumption another very important point
is that for most serious cases there's
universal public insurance which is
known as MediShield that costs only 16
dollars a month for a 30 year old person
and with it of course comes the
possibility of hiring other private
insurers that improve the services
offered
finally the third leg of Singapore's
health system is public expenditure
itself what happens if someone cannot
cover their medical bills
well to guarantee access to healthcare
the government subsidizes hospitals and
has a public funds the meta funds which
is designed to pay health bills for
lower-income families so folks this is
how Singapore has managed to create a
relatively economical medical system
while achieving results in quality
levels that place it among the best
health systems in the world according to
the World Health Organization and
different rankings such as Bloomberg's
most efficient healthcare systems
[Music]
however despite all of this when we
usually talk about healthcare in the
free market we automatically think of
the United States since not Singapore
which is a serious mistake USA versus
Singapore yes indeed the US does not
have a european-style public health
system and since the country's results
are quite deplorable considering that it
spends more than 17% of its GDP on its
health care system which is twice that
of most European countries to the debate
on health it seems settled private
health care is worse than public health
care because it costs twice as much and
has similar or even lower service levels
but this as we saw in Singapore where
60% of health spending is private simply
isn't true in Singapore the health care
system isn't only better it's one of the
best in the world and it involves much
lower costs than in other developed
countries the issue is that the US
healthcare system isn't only heavily
intervenes upon and it's regulated by
the government its cost is tremendously
socialized see 90% of all health
spending is channeled through two
different agents other than the
patient's out of every hundred dollars
spent in the US health system 45 comes
from insurance companies 45 from state
programs such as Medicaid and only 10%
from patients pockets
[Music]
yep public health spending in the United
States is in relative terms higher for
example than in Spain but we're going to
talk about that in another video the
fact is that as we've seen Singapore
sets a healthcare system model on the
table that has a great combination of
cost innovation and medical results we
may like some aspects of the system and
not others but I think it wouldn't be
unreasonable to take it into accounts
when talking about health the future and
sustainability so I really hope you
enjoyed that video please do hit that
like button if you did and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcaster you
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine
also this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on the platform
of patreon please do consider joining
them and supporting us in our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always see in the next video
[Music]
you